Dear friends, that feeling that only sports can give touches the whole world.
Mr. President, the Olympic movement has enjoyed a golden era of more than 20 years...
...because of clear and strong leadership,...
...because of the strategic decisions of its members and because of its timeless values.
New generations of young people have benefited and I'm delighted that one of them is here.
The first ever Youth Olympic Games gold medalist, triathlete Yuka Sato.
We are proud that our athletes have competed since Stockholm in 1912.
And prouder still that they have competed in the true spirit of Olympism,...
...with not a single Japanese athlete ever failing a doping test at the Olympic and Paralympic Games.
Not just because of legislation,...
...but because of a long-standing and unified approach by government, the NOC and national federations,...
...who all agree that we must support athletes and uphold the integrity of the Olympic values.
That commitment to the Olympic values is at the heart of this, our second consecutive bid,...
...a bid in which we have focused on what matters to you today.
First, which city will best continue the financial and sporting success of the movement?
Second, which city offers guaranteed delivery of superb games?
And finally, which city goes beyond a national agenda and has a global vision...
...to promote the Olympic values in this challenging era for sports?
These days, sport itself is in competition, and too often, its credibility is at stake...
...because of doping, illegal betting and match fixing.
In Japan, in the last two years, we have seen the best of sport.
It has inspired our global vision and fed our determination to share the inspiration,...
...so that the entire Olympic family benefits from our three core strengths.
Delivery, because Tokyo can be trusted to be the safe pair of hands and much more.
Celebration, because Tokyo will host an incredible city center party like never before.
And innovation, because Tokyo will offer all its creativity and technology to benefit sport worldwide.